what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video i'm going to make you guys
experts on the timekeepers but here's
the funny thing about this
the timekeepers much like the time
variance authority don't
have a lot of appearances in marvel
comics and in fact the timekeepers
themselves have appeared in 39
comic books across the history of marvel
comics that's how few times they've
appeared right i mean they just don't
have a whole lot that they do but
whenever they do get involved things are
pretty significant right so
the time keepers are actually based off
the time twisters and so whenever people
say that the timekeepers first appeared
in thor number 282
that's actually not correct the
timekeepers first appeared and thor
number 245 and it was actually based off
an existing story that goes all the way
back to thor issue
242. all of this of course was written
by lynn wine and so the whole idea
behind this is that somewhere along the
line
thor was suddenly attacked by what
seemed like this giant sentient being
right this enormous monster and then
over the course of those
issues leading into 245 he ended up
finding himself and jane foster along
with a handful of others were being
attacked by the time twisters and so as
they began to sort of go through this
this kind of tracing back where the time
twisters came from we got a kind of
origin for them and this all basically
coalesced in the future with a being who
was referred to as
he who remains now he who remains was
basically the last member of the time
variance authority to ever exist
before the end of the universe and one
of the things that marvel's always hit
on whenever it comes to the creation of
the multiverse different things like
that that yes
alternate realities are oftentimes
created by the result of an action right
spider-man keeping the venom symbiote
instead of getting rid of it the
avengers never forming different things
along those lines but
universes also die naturally it's called
a heat death and so when universes die
they're basically reborn into a new form
and that happens almost as often
as divergent realities forming as a
result of just characters making
arbitrary decisions and so the result of
this is that the universe was inevitably
going to end naturally right the heat
death the universe collapsing in on
itself and so in order to ensure that
the next generation
that came into existence or the next
universe that was born could essentially
correct all the mistakes of the previous
universe before it he who remains had
created three beings that would
basically
live on into the next universe and were
essentially living knowledge
and they would teach that universe
everything it needed to know in order to
make the best possible decisions
the problem with this is they became the
time twisters and so instead of being
these individuals that would be born
into the next universe and improve
things they actually started going
backwards in time and so they would kind
of appear every
3000 years and they would cause all
kinds of problems and this was the trail
that thor and jane foster along with a
few other people had basically stumbled
upon and so in realizing that the time
twisters were quite literally destroying
reality
they traveled all the way to the end of
time and met with he who remains to
effectively warn him of what his
creations were going to do
now there wasn't a direct explanation in
terms of how we got
from the time twister's origin and and
how they came into existence
running up to the time twisters until
2005. and this was done with a story
called marvel knights
four so it was basically the marvel
knights version of the fantastic four
those of you guys who don't know marvel
knights was basically marvel having a
company called event publications
make their comics for them because they
were almost broke after the coming bus
to the 90s that's why you see marvel
knights but this was part of a story
that was called divine time and the
whole idea behind this is that it gave
us this explanation
that in the aftermath of thor and jane
foster and all them visiting he who
remains
that he ended up basically dismantling
and getting rid of the time twisters by
killing off their life support
and then recreating them in the form of
the time keepers
now unlike the time twisters who
basically sought knowledge at the
beginning of time
the time keepers actually exist to
maintain their own existence right
that's really the the whole point of
them that's why you see them crossing
over with a whole bunch of individuals
one of the first time this happened was
explained
in thor number 282 when you basically
came across what was called space
phantom now space phantom is an
interesting concept
uh a lot of the history that we know
about the space phantom is
essentially a lie that he kind of makes
up his own history so he's kind of
similar to the joker in that way that we
don't definitively know
we did originally get an origin when we
first saw him or at least not really
when we first saw him that was back in
the old avengers comics but in the
follow-up in thor 282 we got an origin
insofar as that his race basically found
a way to master time travel before they
mastered space travel which led to a big
cronal war between all of them but then
later on marvel changed it and they kind
of
danced on that a little bit and saying
like maybe his origins real maybe it's
not that kind of a thing
but what ended up happening is that
somewhere along the line because of the
fact that kane the conqueror was so
involved in the nature of time travel
that he was eventually conscripted by
the time keepers for a couple different
purposes
the first one was to monitor all of time
between 3000 bc
and 4000 ad and make sure that there
were no credible threats that would
arise
that would become an enemy of the time
keepers now initially immortus wouldn't
really do this
or at least kang wouldn't really do this
but the nature of the timekeepers is
they have the ability to manipulate all
facets of time so if they appear to you
they could de-age you down to nothing
right or they could age you all the way
up until you're like minutes away from
dying
and just leave you there right but they
don't usually get involved personally
they usually send agents to do their
bidding for them but one of the things
that had happened here and this was kind
of interesting
while the timekeepers themselves didn't
actually receive an origin
in until thor 282 and really even with
marvel knight's fantastic four issue
number 16
that what you actually ended up getting
was marvel coming back through a
combination of different stories really
across their landscape
especially when he got into the mark
wade fantastic four run and kind of go
back and change things and so what we
ended up learning here is that when you
initially had space phantom who first
showed up
and encountered the avengers in issue
number two that what we ended up
learning is that that was done
at the behest of the time keepers that
the avengers would at some point become
a credible threat to the time keepers
themselves
when that threat would be we didn't know
but it was the desire of the time
keepers to eliminate the avengers before
they become a threat
and so that was when space phantom was
first introduced with avengers issue
number 10
back in 1964 by stan lee and jack kirby
the first time you saw a mortise appear
in marvel comics that was an action of
the time keepers and so it was one of
those instances where you had these kind
of characters who would appear
and they would face off against the
avengers and there seemed to be no real
useful purpose for them outside of
stanley and jack kirby just wanted to
tell a story and then marvel following
up a couple decades later and saying
actually there was a motivation behind
this and it was all the time keepers who
were doing it so again that's one of the
interesting concepts you get when you
start manipulating with time in marvel
comics now one of the other interesting
aspects
of the time keepers is that we also saw
them crossing over in a bunch of
different stories as well
right for example if you go back and you
look at quasar volume 1 issue number 30
while it doesn't necessarily
have to do with any major conflict that
was going on
you actually see the time keepers
encountering the watcher this is kind of
interesting thing because marvel kind of
bounced back and forth they never really
gave us a definitive answer as to
whether or not it was the time keepers
or the time twisters who had somehow
returned
but quasar number 30 of course was
written by tom defalco and for all you
batman fans out there was actually drawn
by greg capullo
but the important thing here is that
they actually encountered the watcher
and because the nature of uwatu is to
basically monitor all of creation
one of the things that he'd also been
doing was monitoring the multiverse but
because the watchers by their definition
are supposed to be non-intervention
under normal circumstances the time
keepers wouldn't really care but because
uwatsu the watcher had actually
intervened in time over different
periods when he first appeared to the
fantastic four
and warned them of the coming of
galactus and other things besides that
the concern of the time keepers or
possibly the time twisters is that uatu
would actually intervene
in alternate realities and in doing so
start creating all kinds of different
problems among the time stream
and possibly even disrupting the
existence of the time keepers themselves
and so they ended up giving him or
allowing him to use a kind of
dimensional portal that let him see
other realities but the ability to
continue using this was predicated on
his ability to go into alternate
realities and destroy those realities
versions of the living laser now the
reason for this is because prior to the
quasar comics arthur parks
was never really a wildly interesting
character right he had like
laser emitting diodes on him and that
was really all he could do but
eventually he gained the ability to
become pure energy
and during a conflict with quasar on the
moon he jumped through one of the
watchers portals to alternate realities
what this did is it created a kind of
multiversal imbalance now this was back
before marvel would like
invoke the living tribunal for all this
kind of stuff and a desire to tell a
story about the time keepers they use
them instead and so because you had the
living laser that was
essentially hopping through different
time periods the desire of the time
keepers was to eliminate this guy and so
that was the watchers task was to
eliminate all the different variations
of arthur parks from across the entirety
of the multiverse now of course by the
end of issue number 30
quasar had gone to this alternate
reality he had snatched up arthur parks
and then brought him back to the main
marvel universe and the day was saved
not a whole lot doing there but the
concern the timekeepers had with regards
to the avengers being a credible threat
to them came to fruition with
probably one of the most significant
stories in the history of the avengers
which was a story called
avengers forever now depending on who
you talked to some people loved
kurt music's avengers forever some
people hated it
it really depends on the person but the
whole idea behind avengers forever is
that it's actually a story that deals
with avengers being pulled onto a
singular team from different timelines
so it's literally all these different
avengers from across time and it was an
awesome concept it was great in terms of
how it was done
but the overall just behind this is that
there's a couple things taking place
here
the first is that there's something
called the destiny force and the destiny
force was originally introduced in the
cree scroll war
when it was bonded to rick jones who was
a long time friend of the incredible
hulk and eventually became a huge friend
of really most of the superheroes on
earth but as essentially this kind of
energy force that imbues
all of humanity and potentially has the
ability to give humanity
incredible powers in terms of exactly
how this works marvel's been pretty
ambiguous about it
i've seen different theories where they
said like the celestials imbued humanity
with the ability to tap into the destiny
force i've also heard other people say
it was just an inherently divine thing
that humanity was just born with and it
was only a matter of time before they
achieved it but the important thing is
that the time keepers came to the
realization that humanity as a whole
possessing the destiny force would be a
credible threat to them the other part
of this was the scarlet witch and the
idea is that with the scarlet witch
being a nexus being or essentially the
kind of focal point for all magic within
a particular universe that the scarlet
witch was destined to be this enormously
powerful being that could be a threat to
the time keepers as well and so the idea
was to have kane the conqueror or
immortus basically bring all these
different avengers together and then set
them up to essentially be destroyed by
the
the time keepers who actually look to
destroy as few universes as possible
in order to nullify or minimize the
effect the destiny force would have so
they wouldn't have to worry about like
the multiversal
whole of humanity possessing the destiny
force and then facing off against them
the issue with this is a mortise did a
couple things
the first is that immortus actually
ensured the scarlet witch would end up
in a relationship with vision by going
back in time and ensuring the two of
them fell in love the second thing
is that he actually allied himself with
the avengers against the time keepers
now the big thing about this and kind of
the big moment for them is that
it's largely eluded by marvel that the
timekeepers were destroyed or at least
disbanded uh in the in the aftermath of
avengers forever we largely haven't seen
them since then
and a big part of that is because
they're pretty much considered to be old
hat their idiot isn't really a reason to
see them anymore
i'm not aware of them being there if
they are it's in a story that i haven't
read in marvel
and i'd like to believe i've read um
current pretty much on all the comics so
maybe it's just something that i missed
but the timekeepers don't currently seem
to exist anymore they might
uh but i don't really think we'll see or
hear from them anytime soon although
with them being in loki
we'll probably see them there and that's
kind of interesting because one of the
big differences between the time keepers
in loki
and the timekeepers as they exist in in
marvel comics is that the time keepers
don't really seem to exist
to preserve their own existence granted
it's possible we don't really know
enough about them all we really know
about
them is that little animation that we
got in the show and the things that
we've seen over the course of the news
leaks and so on and so forth that they
created the time variance authority and
that's really it but how deep and how
far reaching the time
the timekeepers go we're not really sure
we do know that like in marvel comics in
relation to king the conqueror for
example that kang has like a giant
multiversal empire right so he rules
entire universes we don't necessarily
know if the time keepers are going to
have something of their capacity
in the comics where they also monitor
huge sections of the entire multiverse
and more or less rule it we don't know
that's really going to be the case we'll
see as time unfolds with the series but
regardless as far as the comic book
stuff goes that's really all there is
again
39 issues not a whole lot due in there
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace